6 15 on your thursday morning so here at
eight news now we know the prices of gas
and groceries are impacting all of us we
want to help out give back to the
community we all share and eight news
now is partnering with albertsons to
gift you a good day we're surprising
shoppers helping pay for their groceries
[Music]
so i met patricia over at the albertans
in the silverado ranch area hi
how's it going she and her husband both
retired feeling the sting of the cost of
living my husband needs new dentures and
he keeps telling me no
we can't afford them he doesn't want to
do it but he needs them so what's
affected you the most gas prices
you can't get anywhere that's when eight
news now ann albertson's decided it was
time for a surprise what if i told you
that we were just gonna decide to make
your day a little bit better we're gonna
gift you a good day today because the
folks at eight news now and albertsons
want to help you pay for your groceries
today oh thank you so much i appreciate
it
patricia was pretty excited that made us
all happy with the crew and hey you
could be next you want to keep an eye
out for the good day team you might be
the next person to be gifted a good day
because we're still going out and
meeting people and handing out those
giant fake credit card things that's the
sign right like if you see us just
shopping regularly you don't see that
big sign that means we're just doing our
own we don't have money to give away all
the time it's just when we get the big
credit card there
good stuff well let's hope her husband
gets his dentures that he needs that's
important she threw him under the bus
right away didn't she
i wanted to go okay